SEAN REYNOLDS IS RINKSIDE.
GETTING READY FOR PUCK D
WHEELER HAS COMPANY, HAS THE
PUCK, TAKES THE SHOT, DOESN'T D
STASTNY WAS CRASHING IN. IT ARO.
HE PUTS IT UP
THE SIDE OF THE NET, HELLEBUYCK
DOESN'T KNOW WHERE IT IS.
ERIKSSON EK,Y WALKED THE LINE RY
WELL AND THEY DO
BENN, SLIDES IT ACROSS.
KULIKOV WILLAN IN ON HIM.
BEHIND THE NET.G FOR TWO FOR
INTERFERENCE.
THE MINNESOTA WILD GET THE FIR
LITTLE COLD, THOUGH, TODAY
>> Greg: AS HE TOLD ME THIS
MORNING, HE'LL BE IN TROUBLE IF
IN.
SCHEIFELE LOOKING TO MEET UP
WITH FOCUSED LD IN BY COLE PERF.
NOW HERE'S SCHMIDT, SCHMIDT HAS
TOM DUBOIS, TAKES THE
SHOT; TALBOT, SAVE!
WHEELER ON t AHEAD GOAL
ON THE POWER PLAY, IT'S 2-1 ON
DILLON PUTS IT ON NET, RIGHT IN
FRONT, THERE'S THE LOOSE PUCK,
SCHEIFELE LOOKING
WHEELER WINS THE SECOND PUCK
BATTLE AND THROWS IT TOUT TO
SCHEIFELE, S SUP TO FOLIGNO.
FOLIGNDS IT
ACROSS, TRYING FOR THE
ONE-TIMER, COULDN'T GET THAT TO
GO, AND THEY PLACE, FINALLY GETS
IN HERE, HAVING A LOT OF FUN ON
THIS ONE.
D TO D
HE PUTS IT DOWN FOR HARTMAN.
HARTMAN ACROSS.
NICE PLAY THERE'S THE SHOT BUT
HARTMAN/KAPRIZOV/ZUCCARELLO
LINE.
IT STARTSS IT UP TOP
FOR MORRISSEY.
MORRISSEY SENDS IT LOW.
STANLEY TAKING A
LOOKING FOR MERRILL.
PERFETTI PUTS IT UP FOR CONNOR,
CONNOR HAS ROOM, CONNOR IN, WHA
MAKES TO CONNOR.
AND THOSE HANDS.MINNESOTA.
HERE'S GOLIGOSKI.AND NOW THE GO
OUT AND KULIKOV WHO TOOK THE
MORRISSEY.
SCHEIFELE SENDS IT  THE GOALIE